ha the turkey the football the movies
each family has their own set of holiday
traditions and that goes for our
favourite celebrities - true story et
spoke with celebs about how they spin
their turkey Deen it's all about family
food sometimes sweatpants sometimes
sports take a look well both touring but
we will get a chance to slow down I'll
get to see my family and just hang and
wear sweats no makeup and that's what I
like do it
yeah we get a break couple days for
Thanksgiving so I'm going home to
Florida yeah I'm excited to see my
family cook together and just spend time
make some cookies you know lots of food
you know moms have to cookies out
everything's happening but also my
brother has two more girls now his wife
so that means isn't Christmas is very
exciting to them as install those little
kids it's a special exciting so it's
kind of that's the focus and then just
good movies good time spin around the
fire yell such that our family is known
for food you know we're known for the
holiday especially things given in
Kwanzaa you know that's that's what we
do and everybody in the community
everybody knows as always shows up just
to get a plate sometimes they have it on
tin foil it's really good it's gonna be
a good one a high obsession yeah so I
started making pies when I was pregnant
brighter that's when it kind of my
hormones I don't know it took me right
to them
pantry and I started baking and then
slowly pies kind of became something
that I really loved to do and then I
started that was what I did for
Thanksgiving one year I was like there's
a bunch of pies Thanksgiving I made like
seven pies and everyone was like what is
this and I was like I love it and then
and then and then it just became the
tradition for us it's just about food
family friends that's it truly we are
gonna fly in the family from Ohio my
parents are coming in my sister
everybody so it's really just a day to
be really lazy and eat a lot of food and
wear stretchy pants and lots of
aggressive color
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]